a much-loved cartoon gets a modern
reboot an oscar-winning superhero movie
gets a sequel and Craven the hunter is
getting his own movie these are the
Marvel projects coming in 2023 Moon girl
and devil dinosaur has been in
development since 2019 when it was
officially announced during d23 the
Animated Series adaptation is produced
by Disney television animation in
partnership with Marvel animation with
Oscar nominee Lawrence Fishburne
attached as co-creator and executive
producer set for a February 10th debut
on Disney Channel and Disney plus the
2023 series will be led by diamond white
as lunella Lafayette AKA Moon girl Fred
tattershore as devil dinosaur Alfrey
Woodard as lunella's grandmother Mimi
and Fishburn as a mischievous trickster
called the beyonder according to the
show's official synopsis The Animated
Series will be following the adventures
of lunella Lafayette a 13 year old Super
Genius who accidentally brings a T-Rex
named devil dinosaur into present-day
New York City through a Time Forte
checks together they must protect the
residents of the Lower East Side from
any potential danger all you need
use space five Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania will once again find Peyton
Reed directing the third installment of
the Paul ruddled superhero franchise the
three cool is currently scheduled for a
February 17 2023 release with all the
major players returning for their roles
after appearing in endgame the film will
also reintroduce Scott's teenage
daughter Cassie Lang not only does it
appear that Cassie will be getting her
own super suit this time around but now
she'll be portrayed by freaky star
Catherine Newton the new film will also
feature the live-action debuts of major
Marvel villains in the form of Modoc and
Kang the Conqueror will be portrayed by
Jonathan Majors comedy Legend Bill
Murray will also play Lord kreiler in
the film following the release of the
official trailer it's been revealed that
the good place actor William Jackson
Harper has joined the ensemble cast as
seen in the trailer Scott hope and
Cassie along with Hope's parents Hank
Pym and Janet Van Dyne get accidentally
transported into the quantum realm after
an invention of Cassie's malfunctions
together they'll embark on an adventure
through the quantum realm where they'll
meet strange new creatures as a secret
Universe gets revealed Nick Fury will
finally be getting a starring role in
the MCU courtesy of the upcoming secret
Invasion series fury made his first
iconic appearance all the way back in
2008's Iron Man when he showed up in a
post-credits scene I'm here to talk to
you about the Avenger initiative since
then Nick Fury has been a constant
thread tying the many separate MCU story
lines together playing pivotal roles in
a number of films from Captain America
the Winter Soldier to Spider-Man far
from home to Captain Marvel in December
of 2020 Disney announced at their
investor Day event that the Nick Fury
series will actually be an adaptation of
the popular secret Invasion storyline
from the comics secret invasion is set
to be a crossover event bringing
together characters from across numerous
MCU properties the storyline in the
comics centers around an invasion of the
skrulls who have already popped up in
the MCU in a decidedly more sympathetic
role than their Comics counterparts in
the comics the shape-shifting skrulls
have secretly invaded Earth taking the
place of some of Marvel's heroes
naturally Samuel Jackson is set to
reprise his role as Fury in secret
Invasion along with Kobe Smulders as
Maria Hill Martin Freeman as CIA
operative Everett K Ross Don Cheadle as
War Machine and Ben Mendelson returning
as Talos his character from Captain
Marvel Coleman Emilia Clark and
Christopher McDonald will also be
joining the star-studded cast as for the
behind the scenes Talent Kyle Bradstreet
who is best known for his work on the
Emmy winning series Mr Robot will serve
as writer and executive producer after
briefly appearing in Thor love and
thunder the Guardians of the Galaxy will
return on May 5th 2023 with their third
and reportedly final installment James
Gunn is officially back as writer and
director with all of the main Guardians
returning for One Last Ride volume 3
will also feature the long-awaited
live-action debut of the powerful Adam
Warlock portrayed by Will Poulter
warlock's involvement was first teased
during the post-credit scene of volume 2
where he was created for the purpose of
destroying the Guardians that my child
is the next step in our Evolution
arguably the most intriguing addition to
the cast is Peacemaker actor chikuri
awuji who's been tapped to play the
villainous High evolutionary as for the
plot marvel.com says Peter Quill will
lead his team in Another Universe saving
Mission while also trying to protect one
of their own members we also know Gamora
will have teamed up with the ravagers
and won't have any memory of her
relationship with Star-Lord and we'll be
getting a lot of Rocket raccoon's tragic
backstory previously Gunn has hinted
that Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 will
be a darker more emotional Journey for
the space traveling team and that will
be the last time we see this iteration
of the Guardians winner of the Academy
Award for best animated feature of 2018
Spider-Man into the spider-verse is
considered by some to be among the
greatest superhero films ever made
thanks in large part to its supremely
innovative animation style we'll see if
Sony can capture lightning in a bottle
twice with Spider-Man across the
spider-verse which will Center on the
burgeoning Romantic relationship between
Miles Morales and Gwen Stacy AKA spider
Gwen joining miles and Gwen for the
sequel will be Spider-Man 2099 hero
Miguel O'Hara voiced by Moon night star
Oscar Isaac and Jessica Drew AKA
Spiderwoman will be voiced by insecure
star Issa Ray Oscar winner Daniel kaluya
will play Hobie Brown AKA spider Punk
and Jake Johnson will reprise his role
of Peter B Parker they'll be facing off
against the spot played by Jason
Schwartzman across the spider-verse will
hit theaters on June 2nd 2023. its
sequel beyond the spider-verse will hit
the big screen on March 29th 2024 4.
while Marvel is keeping quiet so far
about what Carol Danvers will be up to
the next time we see her we do know that
she won't be alone the film that was
originally presented as a sequel to
2019's Captain Marvel was revealed in
2021 to actually be a team of feature
titled the Marvels Brie Larson will be
returning as Carol Danvers AKA Captain
Marvel but joining her this time around
will be Tiana Paris who was introduced
in one division as a grown-up version of
Monica Rambo and Iman villani who burst
onto Disney plus is Carol Danvers number
one fan girl Kamala Khan aka Miss Marvel
as the only character in the trio
without Marvel in her name the title of
the Marvels suggests that Monica Rambo
will see her fully embracing her
identity as a superhero the comics have
seen her take a number of names
including Photon spectrum and even
Captain Marvel meanwhile Kamala Khan
unlocked her own superpowers after
finding a mystical Bengal fighting the
clandestines connecting with both her
culture and her family and discovering
she's both a gin and a mutant all before
accidentally swapping places with her
Idol Harold Danvers as for the plot we
know the film will pick up immediately
after Miss Marvel but the specifics are
being kept under wraps for now the
Marvels will be helmed by Candyman
director Mia DeCosta and will be soaring
into theaters on July 28 2023.
Marvel's Disney plus series Loki was
full of surprises not the least of which
was that the show will be getting a
second season the first season of Loki
saw the trickster God apprehended by the
time variance Authority thanks to his
actions in Avengers end game where he
deviated from the original timeline by
stealing the Tesseract and escaping
instead of being transported back to
Asgard to be tried for his crimes once
at the TVA he teamed up with agent
Mobius and another Loki variant named
Sylvie to uncover the secrets behind the
time controlling agency the first season
ended with the introduction of he who
remains who promised his even more
dangerous variant Kang the Conqueror
would be appearing soon we know Majors
as Kang will first be appearing in
Ant-Man in the wasp quantumania and that
he'll definitely be a factor in Loki
season 2. the finale also stranded Loki
in an alternate Dimension TVA where no
one knew him the returning cast will be
joined by someone who's a Marvel rookie
but a Multiverse veteran kiwei Quan of
everything everywhere all at once Fame
it's also has been reported that Kate
Dickey of Game of Thrones will allegedly
be playing a villain however whenever
Loki does return it'll be in the hands
of new directors season one director
Kate Herron will be replaced by Justin
Benson and Aaron Moorhead in addition to
critically acclaimed films like spring
the endless and synchronic the duo has
previously worked on Moon Knight which
is what reportedly landed them the Loki
gig among the more interesting projects
Sony has planned for their
spidey-centric universe is a solo
vehicle starring the classic villain
Sergey kravenov AKA Craven the hunter
descended from an aristocratic Russian
bloodline prevnov has dedicated his life
to becoming the world's greatest hunter
and no Quarry has ever stoked his
obsession quite like Spider-Man while
we're unsure of the plot we know the
screenplay will be penned by The
Equalizer 2 scribe Richard wenk and
screenwriting Duo art Markham and Matt
Holloway MCU veteran Aaron Taylor
Johnson who portrayed the ill-fitted
quicksilver in Avengers Age of Ultron
will be taking on the lead role as
Craven the hunter you didn't see that
it's coming
in addition to the solo film Taylor
Johnson reportedly signed on for
appearances in multiple other movies as
well indicating that the Craven film is
likely to be just the beginning of the
character's Arc in the Sony spiderverse
joining Taylor Johnson and Craven the
hunter will be Oscar nominee Ariana
Dubose as the voodoo priestess and
possible crave and love interest Calypso
Fred heshinger as Craven's half-brother
chameleon and Christopher Abbott as the
mercenary assassin The Foreigner who
will act as the film's villain Oscar
winner Russell Crowe who made his MCU
debut as Zeus in Thor love and thunder
will also be appearing in the film in an
undisclosed role as will Levi Miller and
Alessandro navola Craven the hunter will
be helmed by triple Frontier director JC
chandor and his scheduled hit theaters
October 6 2023 mutant fans get excited
for X-Men 97 a Revival of the popular
90s Animated Series this marks Marvel
Studios first confirmed X-Men centered
project which is currently slated for
the fall of 2023 with 10 episodes it
hails from head writer executive
producer Beau de Mayo who's previously
worked on The Witcher and Moon Knight
and the creative team behind the
original show director Larry Houston and
showrunners Eric and Julia leewald will
be Consulting on the series along with a
cast of newcomers X-Men 97 will feature
the return of the original voice cast
some are set to reprise their roles from
the original series While others have
been tapped for new characters images of
First Look concept art have confirmed
the appearances of Wolverine Rogue
Gambit Cyclops Jubilee storm Jean Gray
and Beast ahead of its long-awaited
debut it's also been announced that
X-Men 97 will be receiving a second
season in a surprising and delightful
announcement in October 2021 Marvel
revealed that a one division spin-off
starring Catherine Hans which he acted
the Harkness was in the works for Disney
Plus in one division Han spent the first
half of the series playing Wanda
envision's nosy neighbor Agnes who
played along with Wanda's sitcom
scenarios however it was ultimately
revealed that Agnes was actually a
centuries-old witch named Agatha
Harkness who'd been secretly pulling
strings behind the scenes of Wanda's
picture-perfect TV ready Town lovely to
finally meet you dear while in the
comics Agatha was a wise elderly witch
who even served as a magical mentor to
Wanda for a time in the MCU Agatha is an
ambitious and power-hungry villain who
absorbed the power of her coven and has
used it to sustain herself for centuries
after a sky-high showdown with Wanda in
the one division finale Agatha was
ultimately trapped by the Scarlet Witch
inside Westview her mind altered to lock
her inner Agnes Persona even as Wanda
released the rest of the town's
residence Marvel hasn't yet announced
whether the Agatha series will take
place prior to Agatha's adventures in
Westview or pick up sometime later
presumably after she's managed to shake
off Wanda's enchantment and regain her
hours however we suspect the latter as
Emma Caulfield Ford will reprise her
role as Westview resident Dottie and
Deborah Joe Rupp will return as well
most likely as Mrs Hart from One
Division deadline has reported that
Aubry Plaza of Parks and Recreation Fame
is set to join the show possibly as the
villain of the series Jack Schaefer of
One Division Fame will serve as
showrunner and we also expect things to
get musical Catherine Hahn said to TV
line who knows there may be a little
song here or there but no one is saying
about that certainly not me in addition
to returning as the director for the
Untitled Shang Chi Sequel and Avengers
the Kang Dynasty Dustin Daniel creden's
newest deal with Marvel Studios includes
the development of a brand new MCU
series which was previously speculated
as a Sean Chi spin-off however according
to the Hollywood Reporter credon's
secret MCU project is actually a
live-action TV adaptation of Wonder Man
a Marvel Superhero created by Stan Lee
Don Heck and Jack Kirby Wonder Man AKA
Simon William is known as one of
Marvel's oldest heroes in the comics
Simon is a celebrity by day and
superhero by night he gained his powers
through an ionic energy experiment done
by Baron Zemo allowing him to have
superhuman abilities such as strength
speed agility durability and more
joining Credit in developing the Disney
plus series is Brooklyn Nine-Nine
producer Andrew guest who will serve as
the head writer meanwhile credit is
expected to Executive produce and direct
one or multiple episodes the outlet
notes that the project is still in the
early stages of development and might
potentially start filming in 2023 even
before the Wonder Man series was
confirmed speculation about the hero's
potential MCU debut was stoked after
fans spotted a picture of Wonder Man in
one of the behind the scenes featurettes
for one division given the hero's
history with Wanda maximoff it's likely
that Marvel Studios might have initially
planned to include Wonder Man in the
series in the comics the character is
also closely linked with vision so it's
always possible that Paul betney's new
new white Vision might show up soon
whether or not Vision appears we do know
who will be playing the titular
character the one and only Yaya Abdul
Mateen II who's appeared in major
projects like Aquaman The Matrix
resurrections and the get down we also
know that at least one memorable MCU
character is making his return according
to variety sir Ben Kingsley will be
reprising his role as The Lovable if
Troublesome thespian Trevor Slattery we
last Saw Trevor in chongqi where he
accompanied the titular hero into the
magical realm of tala it makes sense
that Trevor would be returning here as
both he and Simon Williams are actors
and it also marks kingsley's reunion
with credit as the casts for the various
Disney plus MCU shows continue to be
fleshed out doors are opening for other
series featuring some of these new
characters such as the case with a new
series centered around the character of
echo who was introduced in 2021's
Hawkeye in the comics Maya Lopez AKA
Ekko is a deaf Native American woman
whose race used by the villainous
Kingpin after he kills her father Echo
has the ability to perfectly mimic other
people's movements similar to Taskmaster
she's also an accomplished athlete and
acrobat as well as an expert marks woman
in Hawkeye Echo is played by newcomer
Allah Cox where she is a high-ranking
member of the tracksuit Mafia seeking
Vengeance against Clint Barton's Alter
Ego Ronin her backstory in the series
remained largely the same as in the
comics including her close relationship
with Vincent d'onofrio's Kingpin who was
first introduced to audiences in
Netflix's Daredevil series although Echo
appeared to have killed Kingpin in the
final episode of Hawkeye The Hollywood
Reporter has announced that the crime
Lord will return for Maya's upcoming
series plus we'll also see Charlie Cox
reprising his role as Daredevil who's a
close associate of Echoes in the comics
there are also rumors that Kristen
Ritter's Jessica Jones will appear as
well deadline has also reported that
every Jacobs of reservation dogs will be
playing a lead character also rumored to
be joining a local Cox in an undisclosed
role is celebrated at Dr Graham green
who received an Academy Award nomination
for his performance in Dances with
Wolves and previously starred alongside
MCU actors Jeremy Renner and Elizabeth
Olsen in 2017's Wind River filling up
the cast with more indigenous actors
lines up with reports that the show will
see Maya go back to her hometown to
reconnect with her Native American Roots
Echoes Comics storylines also
significantly intersect with moon
Knights who led his own Disney Plus show
additionally in the comics Echo was the
first person to carry the mantle of
ronin before Clint Barton took it over
although in the MCU Barton was the
original vigilante Whose actions
directly impacted Maya Lopez's life we
don't yet know if these Comics details
will make an appearance in the show the
showrunner for the series is Marion dare
who's also worked on Better Call Saul
chanteron and the ACT speaking with the
writer's panel podcast dare revealed the
show wouldn't hit Disney plus until
December 2023.
foreign